Hello Freak bitches.
The NCAA is,
isn't this a whole nother conversation?
Those,
those crooks don't pay their employees.
But as far as the NFL,
you get compensated and you,
you know,
the risks for the most part,
the risks going into the NFL.
Like I chose to to,
to do this as it at a young age.
I'm glad you just said that those crooks don't pay their employees.
Get out is a dark and dirty fucking business.
College sports.
I hate it.
I hate it and I don't have anything to do with it,
but I watched it.
I'm like,
that's cool when you find out how much those fucking schools get from all those
people in order to make sure that their team is successful because the Alma
maters want to,
yeah,
we fucking won again and they get billions of dollars.
There are fucking huge,
huge business and the athletes don't get paid anything.
Nah,
man,
I,
I've,
I've told many,
many times I've told my side of that story,
man.
Uh,
I don't,
I'm not a fan of the NCA.
No,
I don't.
I'm not a fan of either.
I think it's,
it's stealing.
I think they're stealing from those athletes.
That's what,
that's what I mean.
If any ruining their careers,
most likely,
if you do four hard years of college football,
what are the odds you're gonna get out of that without a permanent injury?
I had,
I think three or four of my surgeries came from college.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's tough.
You're playing for free and you pay for,
and my buddy,
hey,
you get an education.
And see that's the thing that kills me man.
When people say,
Hey,
yeah,
I like to say that.
I hate that.
So when I first went to school,
I wanted to study astronomy.
Like that was what I wanted to study.
So I went to my,
uh,
academic advisor and I was like,
okay,
this is what I want to do.
Like it took me like a year to figure out,
okay,
this is what I do.
I was,
I was in love with the stars and the kind of,
that's one of the,
I just wanted to know about it.
And as soon as I said it like,
Oh,
you can't do that.
I was like,
why?
He's like,
because the,
those classes conflict with the practice schedules in the meeting schedules.
And I was like,
well shit.
And so I had to wait another year in order to find what I wanted to do and ended
up settling for a philosophy,
which was a cool major,
but it wasn't,
it didn't,
I felt like if I would've got influenced by by,
uh,
astronomy early on,
then it would've changed.
My trajectory would have changed the way I thought about a lot or I'd arrive to
the conclusions that I met now a lot sooner.
Yeah.
The,
the whole,
you're getting an education thing.
What are you getting a real education?
Hell No,
I know it was,
it's about,
it's about a month,
maybe a month or three weeks after the season before you go into spring ball,
which is like,
you're up at five in the morning,
lifting and running,
Yada,
Yada.
Um,
but there was like a three,
three week period where they leave you alone and,
and you're just like a regular student.
And I did not know what to do with my time.
Like,
I'm like,
how?
How are these,
how are these people not ace in that class?
It's like I didn't understand like how,
I mean granted they were taking tougher courses,
but it's just like you have so much time.
I didn't know what to do with my time because before,
whereas before I'm up early in the morning,
lifting weights,
running,
then go into class.
Then after class get a little lunch,
then go to another class.
Then you come back in,
you're in meetings and after meetings you go to practice and after practice you
can find some kind of energy to study.
Yeah,
we'll get,
give me a,
so like you,
what time of morning would you get up?
So when you're in school usually,
usually I had it,
some of the most of it.
Most of my classes were at eight o'clock classes,
so,
so 8:00 AM you're up now is up before that.
So,
so independent on a day.
So you have to get a workout in depending on everybody's,
every strength coach has a different protocol.
So you have to get lift at least three times a week,
three,
three to two to three times a week.
And so you either lift before class or before practice or after practice.
So you have to,
you have to find your time after practice has got to be hard,
right?
Yeah.
To your,
yeah.
Really.
Then you're just kind of going through the motions.
So,
but do you,
do you want to do it before practice because then you might be tired when you're
going to practice.
He might not perform up to the best of your abilities.
I,
I was not the best day.
I used to get in trouble a lot cause I was like dog,
there's no way you guys can expect me to do all of this shit.
I used to get in trouble for skipping weeks,
uh,
and I wasn't big on weight to anyway.
I'm like,
I was like,
I I didn't see like,
cause we had a lot of Olympic weight lifting.
That's kind of changing too.
We had a lot of like dead lifts and squats and shit like that.
And I was never a fan of that stuff.
I was like,
this is not a conducive to being successful.
What do you think is plateaus?
Plateaus?
Uh,
um,
like yoga,
yoga would real,
yeah.
If we had like a yoga,
I'd have been there every time.
Cause it's like you're,
you're getting loose.
You're any kind of,
um,
you're being limber is more important than being strong in my opinion.
Especially in my position and my position.
I mean there's some,
there's some positions like the and offensive lineman where you gotta you gotta
push.
Um,
but I,
I'm not one of those pieces.
I wasn't one of those positions being a running back.
It's like dbs receivers like stay limber and stay hydrated.
We're good nutrition.
So for you it's more important to,
to be flexible and to be able to move your body and like very fluid ways.
So to be able to avoid take downs,
they will avoid somebody trying to tackle you.
You,
you,
you more pliable is better in my opinion.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
That's an interesting way of looking at it.
So you would,
uh,
they would force you to do certain amount of lifts.
Yeah.
You got to do certain amount of lifts and then you got to go to class and you
got to stay up.
And then when you're doing these lifts are they supervised or you have to do
when you're young coaches in there.
So that's another thing that bothered me too.
He's like,
I was like a rebel man cause it's like they would follow you around the weight
room.
Right.
Cause cause some guys liked to like,
you know,
uh,
try to try to jerk the system and I'm like this is what I want to do with my
life.
Like I'm not going to cheat myself.
Like stop following me around.
Yeah.
It was like a weird,
and then they have class checkers that follow you.
Make sure you go to class,
class check.
And it's just like Bro,
like I just feel like a little kid,
man.
I get out of my face and stuff like after awhile that just wore on me and like
the whole system more.
I mean and on top of that,
like I'm hungry and I don't,
you know what I'm saying?
You don't got to food.
I don't,
people don't get on me again.
People from Tennessee hate me bro.
It's weird.
But I'm from Tennessee.
Why?
As I went to,
I went there and for some reason,
anytime I say anything about the NCA,
they think I'm talking about tenancy itself.
It's weird.
They're like,
fuck you man.
Like I still have people who like to this day,
matter of fact,
yesterday and my mentioned stuff about,
um,
like fumbles I had from like 10 years ago.
It's weird man.
People that awkward man.
Well,
people love to bring up things that you've done wrong,
but I was like 18 years old being love it and love it.
It's funny man.
It is funny.
What are you going to know?
So you would get up in the morning and you would have to figure out when you're,
so would you schedule your lifts in?
Well,
it's not,
it's not necessarily a schedule is more like a,
um,
whatever suits your schedule the best.
So if you have an eight o'clock class,
you'd get,
you have to go before class or whenever your break is during.
How many classes are you doing today?
Uh,
it's probably like two or three.
And what you supposed to keep a certain GPA?
Yeah.
2.5.
So you have to keep up to point.
What does that look?
A C average or something.
See,
yes,
he averages.
So you would,
you go to your class,
you do whatever you gotta do.
And then how many times a day are you practicing?
A once a day.
Once a day.
You have meetings,
meetings are like an hour 30 and the meetings are essential.
They're going over strategy and go,
yeah,
you get your playbook,
your game plan,
um,
watch film on the other team or yourself.
Is it hard to motivate yourself watching all that shit?
Yeah,
after a while for me,
cause I,
I'm a,
quarterbacks are different.
They don't have to,
um,
exert as much physical energy as we do.
And they're,
they're more on a mental game.
So they have to know the defensive games that the defensive coordinators plan.
Right.
So what covers day and wider,
what the safeties or don't have to know all of that as a running back,
you kind of have to know.
But,
um,
not as much.
You kind of just have to know where their blitzes are coming from.
Oh boy.
You with the,
with the intricacy.
But uh,
after awhile I got it.
I didn't need to watch how much film in order me to get my assignment then I saw
a lot of time.
I'm just sitting there wasting time.
I was like,
you guys felt like that too.
Yeah,
I would imagine you're sitting there watching some stupid plays.
I always told my coaches,
especially in the league,
like you could give me my game plan like Saturday before the game and I execute
like I didn't need,
I think a lot of what they do in the NFL just reinforcement.
It's just oh,
oh.
And it's repetition,
it's repetition.
And after a while,
especially if you're a veteran,
like you don't need,
that's why Brett Farve like when he was um,
deciding on whether to come back or not,
he was like,
I,
I would love to,
but I,
all that other shit.
I don't like doing all that,
the meetings and that,
that's what kept him back here,
man.
It really is.
It gets old.
It gets a super old man and you don't if,
if you know what you're doing and you will,
when you were a well versed in your crap,
you're on,
you don't need half of that shit.
And this is terrible for the younger cast at,
of listening to this.
Yeah,
I need it,
man.
Well,
something about a guy like Brett Farve too,
with all that fucking gray hair,
old grizzled,
old veteran who a it bill still wanting to do it.
I hated to go crazy.
Right?
Go right.
It's just crazy.
They still wanted to do it.
I mean,
how many times does that guy been dinged as what I'm saying?
I don't,
don't get hit a lot though.
Like I get hit enough.
Yeah,
man.
You know Jim Mcmahon.
Okay.